Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Comme promis, après trois épisodes consacrés à la politique belge, on prend une petite respiration et on revient à des sujets plus légers.
Cette semaine, je passe septante minutes avec nul autre que Myriam Leroy, journaliste, auteure, chroniqueuse. Elle s'identifie comme féministe radicale et défend que son journalisme est une forme d'art.
Il n'en fallait pas plus pour capter mon attention. Un épisode pépouze donc, qu'on a enregistré avec une Myriam ensevelie sous une couverture parce qu'elle avait la crève.
Ça se déguste sans modération et c'est maintenant. Let's go ! Et bonjour à tous. Aujourd'hui, mon invitée est une journaliste.
Elle a travaillé entre autres pour La Libre, pour Le Soir Magazine, pour L'Écho et pour un peu toutes les publications, presses en Belgique.
Elle est ensuite devenue chroniqueuse pour la RTBF sur La Première, ensuite coupée au montage également, auteure de théâtre, romancière.
Un parcours très diversifié. Myriam Leroy, salut.
Salut.
Ah, ça fait une carrière, comme je disais, quand même assez variée, assez diversifiée parce que…
Je suis le Rémi Briquet de…
C'est ça. Est-ce que tu es satisfaite de ce portrait ? Est-ce que tu te sens définie ?
Oui et non. En fait, je remarque que quand on dit de moi que je suis chroniqueuse, ça m'énerve.
Ah.
Mais c'est peut-être parce que j'ai tendance à me la péter un peu. Mais parce que ce n'est qu'une infime partie de mon parcours.
Et j'ai surtout été journaliste. Et puis là, ça fait quelques années que je suis…
Ouais.
…surtout autrice quoi.
Je ne voudrais pas résumer au…
Non, non, tout à fait. Mais c'est parce qu'on me présente souvent, quand on doit trouver un bandeau, quand je passe à la télé ou quoi sur l'écran, c'est toujours chroniqueuse.
Et je me dis : mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on a toujours envie de me réduire à ça ? Même si ce n'est pas un sot métier.
C'est peut-être le truc le plus visible. Les gens te connaissent…
Sûrement.
…surtout pour les Myriam Leroy n'aime pas plus que pour les articles dans L'Écho, je pense.
Oui, oui, alors que ça date.
Oui, oui, c'est vrai. Donc, ouais, c'est… j'avais vu le documentaire que j'avais beaucoup aimé, J'adore les Belges…
Ouais.
…dans lequel tu passais. D'ailleurs, je crois qu'on est…
On est dans les lieux du tournage.
Dans les lieux du tournage, c'est très intimidant. Il y a eu un chapitre assez court, assez traumatique, on va revenir là-dessus, où tu es passée de l'autre côté de la frontière…
Mmm-hmm.
…où tu es allée travailler à Paris…
Ouais.
…chroniqueuse à Paris. D'où ça t'est venue l'idée d'aller bosser chez les Français alors que voilà, tu les dépeins comme étant le discours habituel, condescendant, arrogant, voilà, le discours classique ?
Ah moi, je ne dépeins absolument pas les Français comme ça. Dans ma première chronique sur Canal Plus, c'était l'espèce de caricature que j'ai avancée, mais c'était pas…
D'accord.
…c'était pas…
Ok. Tu n'en penses rien ?
Non, moi, en fait, je me suis sentie très très bien accueillie à Paris et je trouve qu'on est globalement mieux accueillis à Paris qu'à Bruxelles, notamment dans les endroits de service, enfin comme les restos ou les guichets ou ce genre de trucs.
Ok.
Moi, je trouve ça vachement plus agréable d'aller boire… enfin, les serveurs, je les trouve plus sympas dans les bistrots parisiens…
Mmm.
…que dans les cafés bruxellois où on est soi-disant à la bonne franquette et tellement, tellement sympathiques. Et alors, travailler en France, moi, c'était pas… j'en avais pas spécialement envie…
Ok. C'était un moment carriériste ?
Non, ils sont venus me chercher, en fait…
Ok.
…à une époque où j'avais fait plein de propositions d'émissions à la… de chroniques à la RTB et tout avait été refusé.
Donc, j'avais en fait… on était, je crois, au mois de… fin juin et c'était plus ou moins la date où les grilles se bouclent.
Mmm.
Et moi, j'avais rien pour la rentrée…
Ouais.
…à part une chronique par semaine dans l'émission d'Olivier Monssens. Et donc, quand ils sont venus me chercher à Canal Plus,
c'était une surprise et ça tombait super bien, notamment pour pouvoir faire les pieds aux gens de la RTBF qui avaient refusé…
Ah oui.
…toutes mes propositions.
C'est la meilleure carte de visite, quoi.
Ouais, ouais.
Ok.
Les gens qui travaillaient dans les médias, bon, je me suis rendu compte assez vite sur place que ce n'était pas du tout le cas.
Mais je suis contente de l'avoir fait, en fait, parce que si je l'avais pas fait, je pense que ça resterait un fantasme. Et là, le fantasme…
C'est ça.
…il a été tué assez vite. Donc, j'ai pu passer à autre chose et me rendre compte que c'était pas fait pour moi quoi.
Ouais, ouais. Tué assez vite, tu dis ça comme ça, mais qu'est-ce qui t'a menée à couper court à cet épisode à Paris ?
Ben, en fait, je trouvais que ce qu'on me demandait de faire n'avait pas d'intérêt. Je devais prendre le train super tôt le matin, je revenais avec le dernier Thalys.
Tout ça pour deux minutes d'antenne. C'était énormément de chichi, de maquillage, habillage, coiffure, tout ça pour des billets hyper courts, alors que moi, j'avais l'habitude de formats quand même de quatre ou cinq minutes en radio
où j'avais l'occasion de creuser un propos,
au-delà des simples vannes, quoi.
Mmm-hmm.
Parce que les vannes, pour moi, ça n'a jamais été qu'un vecteur pour raconter autre chose. Ça n'a jamais eu d'intérêt en soi.
Et là, ça réduisait mon champ d'action à la simple chronique humoristique, quoi, la simple…
Ouais.
…accumulation de punchlines. Et non seulement ça m'intéresse pas, et en plus, j'étais pas très bonne là-dedans. Moi, j'étais… il y a aucune des chroniques que j'ai faites pendant cette année-là dont je suis fière.
J'avais l'impression de brasser du vent chaque semaine. Donc, arrivée à la fin de la saison, ils m'ont proposé de rempiler.
J'ai trouvé ça gentil et flatteur et…
C'est ça.
…mais je n'ai pas réfléchi longtemps avant de dire non.
Ouais, la meilleure rémunération, entre guillemets, c'était la carte de visite, c'était le fait de pouvoir dire : « Voilà, maintenant, je suis dans la cour des grands, donnez-moi du boulot à La Première. »
Oui, oui, voilà, exactement. Mais ceci dit, c'était… alors, c'était pas hyper bien payé parce qu'on se fait toujours des…
Ouais, ouais.
…montagnes des salaires français, mais c'était exactement comme les salaires belges.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais en termes de droits d'auteur, là, pendant plusieurs années, j'ai continué à toucher des droits de replay, notamment de territoires d'outre-mer.
Donc c'est quand même intéressant aussi. Amis, amis journalistes belges qui voulez franchir le Rubicon, ben, pensez à vos droits de replay.
Ok, ok.
C'est intéressant financièrement.
Tu parles donc des chroniques que tu faisais. Donc c'était dans une nouvelle édition avec Ali Baddou. Il y en a une, notamment, qui a beaucoup fait le tour des Internets,
où tu t'es attaquée à un monsieur qui s'appelle Dieudonné.
Mmm-hmm.
C'est vrai que, bon, j'ai fait ma petite recherche et quand on cherche les tweets qui mentionnent Myriam Leroy côté 2013, 2000, voilà, c'est pas très élégant.
C'est un doux euphémisme.
Oui, oui.
Ce sont principalement des menaces de viol et de mort hein.
Voilà, et des photomontages…
Et de mort par viol.
…des photomontages très douteux.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que… est-ce que… ben oui, je posais la question simplement : est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, tu regrettes cette chronique ?
Ben non, pfff. Non, je… 'fin, je sais pas. À refaire, je le ferais sans doute pas, hein, parce que ça m'a quand même causé pas mal d'emmerdes et occupé trop l'esprit.
Et puis ça m'a quand même considérablement désespérée sur la misogynie ambiante. Mais en fait, à cette époque-là, je trouvais ça juste.
'fin, je trouvais que c'était… alors, c'était peut-être pas la forme idéale. Peut-être qu'en deux minutes, c'est certainement beaucoup trop court pour tailler un costard à quelqu'un sur des sujets si sensibles.
Mais voilà, ma démarche me semblait juste et empreinte de bon sens. Et donc, je n'ai absolument pas honte du tout de ce que j'ai dit.
Voilà, c'est tout ce que je peux dire. Mais la séquence qui a suivi a été extrêmement pénible pour des tas de raisons.
Et notamment celle qu'on ne met pas assez en avant, c'est, je trouve, l'absence totale de confraternité dans le paysage médiatique belge qui, en fait, s'en est plutôt amusé. 'fin…
Oui, on en parlait des pages plutôt people, plutôt Morandini, etc. Que…
Voilà, c'était ça. Comme si c'était un clash alors que ça n'a absolument rien à voir. Et comme si c'était un truc entre deux personnalités alors que ça n'a rien à voir non plus.
'fin, c'était un concept quoi, plus que…
Tu penses que si un homme avait fait cette chronique, ça aurait été traité différemment ?
Mais bien sûr. Mais d'ailleurs, c'est pas je pense, je l'ai constaté, trois semaines après moi, Nicolas Bedos a fait une chronique sur Dieudonné aussi.
Et bon, elle est pas bien passée hein, sa chronique. Et elle a eu beaucoup de retentissement parce qu'il avait une exposition médiatique évidemment bien plus importante que la mienne.
Mais quand on le menaçait, c'était de lui foutre une claque dans la gueule, pas de l'exciser, de l'arroser de sperme de rabbin.
Et voilà, donc il y avait une dimension hypersexo aussi spécifique à toutes les menaces et insultes que j'ai reçues.
Et j'en ai reçu des dizaines de milliers hein, et ça a duré des années. Parce que…
Aujourd'hui, c'est terminé, tu…
Oh, y a toujours bien un débile qui se réveille une fois de temps en temps et qui m'envoie un message en me disant : « Sale petite pute de quartier, on va t'avoir parce que t'as dit sur Dieudonné. »
Ah ouais, ok. D'accord.
Mais oui, non, ça s'est quand même considérablement calmé. Mais non, non, mais bien, bien sûr. Stéphane Guillon aussi avait fait quelques semaines plus tard…
Bon, mon problème, c'est que j'étais aussi la première, donc j'essuyais les plâtres un peu. Et puis voilà, j'étais une meuf.
Donc ouais, je me suis pris toute une violence qui n'est pas équitablement distribuée entre les hommes et les femmes.
Ton… le, voilà, le féminisme, ton engagement contre le sexisme, c'est un sujet qui revient de manière assez récurrente à travers, voilà, tous les sujets qui sont les tiens, le journalisme, entre autres.
Ça t'est venu comment ? J'ai envie de dire, c'est une bête question, mais à la fois très complexe.
Qu'est-ce qui a démarré, en fait, cette préoccupation ?
Ben, je pense, l'enfance. 'fin, j'ai grandi dans un environnement très tradi où les rôles étaient fort divisés…
D'accord.
…et où l'horizon des possibles n'était pas le même quand on naissait garçon ou quand on naissait fille.
J'ai envie de dire que des filles comme ça, j'en connais et elles remettent pas forcément en question, voilà, les rôles genrés, elles remettent pas forcément en question ce système qui impose un rôle…
Non, non, c'est quitte ou double hein. Soit tu passes du côté obscur de la force et tu te conformes à ce qu'on attend de toi.
Et puis moi, ça a toujours été… j'ai toujours été fort réfractaire à l'autorité et à l'arbitraire, en fait.
L'arbitraire a toujours été quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup dérangée. 'fin, pas dérangée, mais que je n'ai jamais bien compris.
'fin, j'ai jamais bien compris comment on pouvait s'en accommoder, de l'arbitraire. Et moi, je ne m'en accommode pas.
Et donc, j'ai toujours beaucoup pinaillé, et j'ai toujours posé beaucoup de questions et il fallait toujours qu'on m'explique parce que voilà, depuis toute petite, les « parce que c'est comme ça », ça ne… je ne…
Oui. Le dogmatisme, le…
Ouais. Et puis ben, donc voilà. Donc j'étais naturellement rebelle à toute forme de tentative de me formater, même si bien sûr, je me suis… 'fin, voilà, la culture m'a formatée…
Le premier son environnement.
…les amis. Oui, bien sûr. Et je sais que je suis moi-même misogyne, inconsciemment travaillée par une conception misogyne de la société, parce que je suis le produit de la société dans laquelle j'ai évolué.
Mais voilà, au fil du temps, j'ai essayé de lire quand même des bases théoriques à tout ça et de m'informer.
Et en fait, je trouve que c'est un sujet absolument passionnant parce que quand on déconstruit ce qu'on appelle de manière un peu caricaturale la domination masculine…
Le patriarcat.
…ouais, ça permet de déconstruire toute forme de domination quoi, et d'envisager d'un œil nouveau toutes les discriminations, le mépris de classe, le racisme, l'homophobie, la grossophobie, l'handiphobie.
'fin, voilà, donc je trouve que c'est vraiment un sujet passionnant.
Donc on avait reçu dans ce podcast, il y a quelques semaines, Alain Jarnot, qui présentait son parcours à la RTBF comme assez idyllique.
Ouais.
Il a pu travailler là-bas dans un environnement très stable. Il a pu faire ce qu'il voulait. Il était très satisfait de sa carrière.
Tous les parcours sont évidemment assez différents. Donc, tu évoquais tout à l'heure le fait que ça n'a pas toujours été facile pour toi de trouver des endroits pour t'exprimer à la RTBF.
Est-ce que toi, tu décrirais ton expérience journalistique à la RTBF comme globalement positive ?
Ben oui et non, en fait. Oui, parce que je ne vois pas bien où travailler d'autre. Quand on a envie de travailler comme journaliste ou comme chroniqueuse, comme éditorialiste…
Lui disait qu'il aurait tout à fait pu travailler pour RTL.
Mais moi pas.
Ouais.
Moi, vraiment pas. Mais sans doute pour de mauvaises raisons et des raisons symboliques qui survivent pas à l'épreuve des faits quoi, parce que…
C'est ça. T'as une dent contre RTL depuis ta tendre enfance…
Non, j'ai pas une dent, mais j'étais très… je souscrivais beaucoup à ce qui est présenté comme les valeurs du service public.
Puis en fait, on se rend compte... parce que moi, j'ai fait mon mémoire, en fait, sur le,
sur une comparaison RTBF, RTL, sur l'utilisation du fait divers dans les journaux parlés radio.
Et je pensais confirmer ce que confusément, intuitivement, on pensait tous, c'est-à-dire que RTL fait son beurre sur les faits divers et la RTBF sur des sujets beaucoup plus nobles.
Et en fait, c'est kif kif quoi. C'est plus ou moins la même chose. RTL les place un peu plus en tête de gondole que la RTBF, en tout cas sur l'échantillon que j'ai analysé.
Mais donc voilà, moi, il y a un petit côté Corée du Nord chez RTL avec cette parade, 'fin voilà tous ces trucs, mais la RTBF en organise aussi hein, mais-
Ouais.
Il me semblait que ça correspondait plus à mes idéaux et ma personnalité de travailler à la RTBF.
Tu parles de quoi quand tu parles de tous ces trucs, toutes ces parades ? Tu penses à quoi ? Tu penses à-
Ben vraiment la parade de Noël RTL où-
D'accord, OK.
Toute l'entreprise-
Oui, OK.
Fait des signes de reine d'Angleterre
à son public réuni en masse, mais ça, ça ramène un monde de dingue hein. Je crois qu'à Bastogne, il n'y avait plus eu autant de monde dans les rues depuis la Libération que quand la parade RTL est passée par là.
D'accord, oui.
Et voilà. Et pour-- alors, la RTBF laisse aussi plus de place à la culture que RTL et que moi, c'est toujours ce qui m'a plus intéressée, notamment quand je faisais mes études.
Donc voilà, je me suis retrouvée à la RTBF parce que je ne voyais-- 'fin pour moi, c'était une évidence quoi. T'as le choix, t'as deux boîtes où bosser, le groupe RTL ou le groupe RTBF. Et 'fin voilà.
T'aurais pu tout à fait continuer dans la presse écrite comme tu le faisais avant.
Oui, ben en fait, je crois-- j'ai toujours été indépendante, donc j'ai toujours travaillé en presse écrite et je continue encore à travailler en presse écrite.
D'accord, donc là, je la con.
Donc ouais, je fais plein de trucs différents en même temps.
Oui. Puisqu'on en parle, de la presse écrite, c'est un marché qui est complètement saturé. On parle tout le temps du fait que c'est difficile de trouver du boulot et que c'est encore plus
difficile quand on est une femme.
Est-ce que ton expérience, j'ai envie de dire, en tant que femme, puisqu'on évoquait, voilà, le sexisme ambiant dans notre société, en tant que femme, est-ce que tu as ressenti
des difficultés particulières en tant que journaliste ?
Alors, à la fois oui et à la fois non, comme ma réponse précédente. Alors oui, parce que je crois très fort qu'on ne me prend pas toujours au sérieux dans mon milieu professionnel parce que je suis une femme.
Je sais aussi que je suis moins payée à un travail équivalent qu'un homme et que les justifications que je reçois sont absolument pas recevables.
Qu'est-ce que tu reçois comme justification, par exemple ?
Que ça, oui, ben c'est parce que machin a, 'fin voilà, plus de charisme.
Ouh là, oui, d'accord. Donc il a un meilleur score sur le charismomètre.
Ouais, ouais.
Ouais. C'est objectif.
Oui, ben oui, c'est très objectif. Donc je sais, je suis à peu près sûre que jamais je ne monterai dans l'organigramme.
Mais d'ailleurs, ce n'est pas mon ambition. Ça a pu l'être sans doute à un moment, mais maintenant, vraiment pas. Je n'ai pas envie de m'emmerder avec des problèmes de chef.
Je trouve qu'on a déjà assez de problèmes quand on n'est pas chef.
Mais-- et d'un autre côté, je crois que le sexisme, 'fin, m'a permis de travailler
parce que je suis toujours celle qu'on vient chercher quand les mecs se sont cooptés entre eux, ont formé leurs équipes et se sont rendus compte à la fin que : "Merde, il y a zéro meuf, ça va jaser.
On va dire que... et il faut en trouver une".
Il faut une meuf qui va compenser, mais très très très fort le manque de femmes. Donc, on va prendre une féministe très vocale.
Non. Ben déjà, je ne suis pas très vocale et je pense que mon côté féministe n'a pas toujours été très apparent.
En tout cas, il n'a pas été très entendu.
D'accord, OK. Je-
Mais je crois qu'il y a tellement peu de femmes, en tout cas dans les émissions un peu plus humour, humeur, machin, que c'est toujours les mêmes qu'on va chercher quoi.
Et donc grâce au fait qu'il y en a si peu, et que moi, je-- par-- je ne sais pas comment j'ai réussi à un moment donné quand même à faire mon trou et à émerger.
Je suis toujours celle qu'on vient chercher à un moment donné, mais pas pour mes talents intrinsèques, mais pour mon profil.
OK, oui, donc-
Ce qui est quand même relativement vexant parce que-
Oui, c'est ça, oui, tu bénéficies du-- ouais, ouais.
Je bénéficie du sexisme jusqu'à un certain point puisque voilà, une fois que j'ai été engagée, ça reste quand même des salaires assez misérables et une perspective d'avenir plutôt bouchée quoi.
Oui, oui. Est-ce que c'est justement cette situation, voilà, financière, peut-être un peu plus difficile qui t'a amenée à diversifier ton champ d'action ?
Voilà, je disais, tu écris du théâtre, tu es romancière depuis l'année dernière. C'est ça-- c'est vraiment pour des questions financières que t'as-
Non, non. En fait, j'étais, moi, journaliste classique hein, à la base. Je faisais des piges en presse écrite. J'ai commencé au Vers l'Avenir Brabant Wallon.
Il y avait-- puis voilà, tout ce que tu as cité au début. J'ai un peu fait le tour de beaucoup, 'fin de beaucoup de rédactions de presse écrite quotidienne et hebdomadaire et même mensuelle.
Mais les piges en presse écrite, 'fin et les piges journalistiques, écrites ou audiovisuelles, c'est payé une misère quoi.
Et en plus, ça demande un investissement. Enfin, je ne l'apprends à personne, mais pour écrire un article, il faut
passer des coups de fil, il faut se déplacer, il faut rencontrer des gens, il faut saturer son sujet, puis il faut y réfléchir et puis il faut trouver un angle.
Enfin voilà, ça prend un temps quand même considérable pour un salaire que je trouve vraiment carrément honteux, en tout cas dans nos contrées.
Qu'une chronique, ben ça occupe en fait exactement le même nombre de caractères sur une page, ou le même temps sur une antenne.
Sauf que tu le fais tout seul avec ton jus de cerveau et que ça prend beaucoup beaucoup moins de temps d'écrire une chronique, même très chiadée, que d'écrire un reportage qui aurait le même volume quoi.
Donc à un moment donné-- et puis en plus, quand tu fais de la chronique, tu peux toucher des droits d'auteur parce que c'est considéré comme une production artistique.
Et donc, bon, les droits d'auteur ne cessent d'être revus à la baisse, mais à une époque, ça me permettait de gagner ma vie de manière satisfaisante.
Ces rémunérations misérables, ces droits d'auteur qui baissent, tout ça, mais est-ce que c'est pas aussi le fait que les gens regardent moins la télé, écoutent moins la radio qu'avant et finalement consomment autre chose tout simplement ?
Est-ce que c'est pas juste un effet de marché ?
Oui, c'est très probablement, mais est-ce que la RTBF doit s'aligner sur le marché ? Je ne sais pas.
Oui, oui, ben en même temps, 'fin, voilà, le fou la poule, est-ce que si tu payais pas un peu mieux tes collaborateurs, ils feraient pas des trucs un peu plus passionnants, un peu moins
par-dessus la jambe et que ça rameuterait pas plus de lecteurs et de spectateurs. Et donc
quand je suis pass-- 'fin, je suis pas passée, mais parce que ça faisait longtemps que je
faisais-- j'écrivais des nouvelles que je publiais dans des recueils ou que je collabore-- j'écrivais pour le théâtre, mais dans des pièces collectives ou des trucs comme ça.
Mais donc j'ai écrit une pièce moi-même toute seule il y a quelques années et puis un roman qui est sorti il y a un an.
C'est pas pour me diff-- 'fin, c'est pas pour des questions financières parce que le roman, c'est ce qu'il y a de moins payé au monde quoi.
Le théâtre, ça va, c'est mieux. Mais le roman, c'est vraiment pour-
Pour le fun.
C'est même pas un défraiement, c'est une petite dringuelle quoi. Mais non, mais je le fais parce que c'est ce que j'ai toujours voulu faire et j'ai toujours voulu m'essayer à ça.
Et puis je ne sais pas, à un moment donné, c'était le bon moment. J'ai fait les bonnes rencontres.
Ouais. Je t'ai entendue par le passé dire qu'à la RTBF, il y avait une collision entre une logique d'administration et une logique créative.
Est-ce que tu maintiens ça aujourd'hui ?
Oui. Oui, oui, ben-
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire exactement ?
Moi, je-- Mais en fait, c'est plus un truc qu'on ressent qu'un truc à expliquer quoi.
D'accord. Ben, dis ce que tu ressens.
Mais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas mal de personnalités... En fait, non, je crois que je prenais un peu mon cas personnel pour des généralités parce que moi, je me suis toujours sentie énormément d'artiste.
Mais beaucoup de journalistes se perçoivent comme des êtres dénués d'affect qui ne font que renvoyer de manière totalement objective une réalité à un spectateur.
Moi, j'ai toujours admis et même cultivé que j'écrivais à partir de ma fenêtre quoi, et que l'objectivité était un leurre absolu.
Donc oui, je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de journalistes à la RTBF qui ne se considèrent pas comme appartenir quand même à quelque chose de la famille du domaine des arts.
Mais moi, j'ai quand même toujours eu un peu l'impression de faire ça, même quand, et peut-être même surtout quand je fais des trucs vachement sérieux qui sont pas des machins de saltimbanque quoi.
Voilà. Tu reviens un petit peu sur ce que tu disais.
Ben disons qu'aujourd'hui, j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire que c'est surtout une logique d'administration.
Mais alors, je ne suis pas-- En fait, la-- je parle pour la chaîne pour laquelle je travaille, les audiences de la Première ne sont pas dingues depuis quelques années déjà.
Ça participe à une forme de démotivation aussi. Mais l'organigramme de la RTBF est en train d'être complètement bouleversé et il se passe quelque chose en ce moment avec, je crois, des personnalités intéressantes et compétentes.
Et je pense que je pourrais, 'fin, j'espère, mais je crois que je vais réviser vite mon jugement quoi. Il me semble qu'il y a quand même un petit frémissement quoi.
D'accord. Et d'où ça vient ? C'est-- il y a justement des budgets qui ont été libérés pour plus de culture, pour plus de-
Non, je crois pas. Mais il y a des gens en fait, qui maintenant sont sans doute au bon endroit.
OK.
Et qui vont allouer le budget qui existe déjà aux bonnes personnes.
Tu émettais une critique tout à l'heure comme quoi la RTBF devait peut-être ne pas subir les effets de marché et au contraire libérer des fonds pour compenser quelque part ce manque de culture dans le paysage médiatique.
C'est pas ce que j'ai dit, mais c'est très bien dit et j'y souscris.
C'est presque ce que tu as dit. Et donc, tu estimes que bientôt le service public fera le boulot du service public tel que-
Ah non, non, non, j'ai pas dit ça. J'ai dit que l'espoir était permis. Mais je comprends aussi, c'est très compliqué.
On voit que la culture, ça ne fonctionne pas. Je ne comprends pas pourquoi alors qu'il me semble que tout le monde lit au moins un livre une fois de temps en temps, va au cinéma une fois de temps en temps.
Mais quand on voit à quelle heure sont programmées les émissions de cinéma ou les émissions littéraires, c'est-- je ne sais pas.
Même en France hein, pas juste à la RTBF, il y a des émissions super comme Stupéfiant de Léa Salamé.
C'est du gros, gros budget et c'est vraiment très très bien fait, mais c'est-- je crois que ça ne cartonne pas du tout et c'est aussi programmé à des heures pas très compétitives.
En gros, il y a quelque chose avec la manière dont on parle de la culture, ou c'est peut-être intimidant pour une partie du public quand ils entendent culture.
Disons que si on est aujourd'hui dans une époque où on peut consommer ces contenus un peu quand on a envie. Quand tu parles de cinéma à la RTBF, je pense à Ciné-Cinéma, par exemple, qui n'est même plus diffusé en radio.
Non.
Mais qui continue à exister dans son coin, à être financé justement par le service public. Et ceux que ça intéresse peuvent le consommer.
Oui.
Est-ce que c'est pas une solution qui marche assez bien finalement ? Puisqu'on est-- plutôt que de la diffuser à minuit et de la réserver à deux, trois personnes qui souffrent d'insomnie, ben on va la diffuser sur Internet.
Est-ce que c'est pas une solution ?
Peut-être, mais moi, je pars de-- 'fin, pour parler de mon parcours personnel, je ne viens pas d'une famille ouverte à la culture.
Donc j'ai dû faire mon propre chemin toute seule. Et c'est grâce au programme de flux, en fait, où on m'imposait des choses que je n'allais pas chercher, parce que je ne sais pas, moi, j'avais des
préoccupations qui étaient loin de tout ça, que je me suis intéressée à des choses dont j'ignorais l'existence quoi.
Donc je crois fort quand même, encore auprès d'un certain public, aux vertus des programmes de flux où on te prend par la main et on te montre quelque chose quoi.
La question, c'est de savoir si ce certain public n'est pas sur le déclin et de plus en plus petit puisque-
Ouais.
Il me semble que les ados sont sur YouTube et pas sur la radio FM en train d'écouter la Première.
Non, ben moi non plus en fait hein.
Oui, c'est ça, moi non plus.
Moi, je-- c'est vrai que je consomme surtout du podcast et des podcasts natifs.
Ouais.
Et ouais, je n'écoute plus trop la radio. À part, ouais, des podcasts de France Inter et France Culture, je reste encore fidèle à quelques émissions de radio belge hein, mais-
Ouais. Tu écoutes encore Ciné-Cinéma ?
Bah, de temps en temps.
Mh.
Je ne sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs.
Mais je pose la question parce que je t'avais entendue t'exprimer comme quoi, voilà, tu-- on parlait des chroniques Myriam Leroy n'aime pas, que tu faisais il y a une dizaine d'années.
Et tu expliquais qu'aujourd'hui, tu avais un petit peu tourné la page et que cracher sur les productions culturelles des autres ne t'intéressait plus.
Tu essayais d'être plus subtile, plus, de ne pas dégommer le travail d'un artiste en trois tournures.
Donc, on le disait aussi, tu as une dent contre le sexisme, pour ainsi dire. Ciné-Cinéma, moi, j'aime beaucoup.
Je l'écoute depuis une dizaine d'années. On peut pas dire qu'ils soient forcément très respectueux du travail de tout le monde.
Et on peut pas dire que les tournures sexistes soient complètement absentes.
Oui, c'est vrai. Mais je trouve que c'est vraiment de la super bonne radio quoi.
Bah oui. Bah oui.
C'est deux-
Bah oui.
Deux espèces de virtuoses de la radio, et-
C'est-
L'un et l'autre quoi. Franchement-
J'étais invité.
Ils sont épatants.
Il m'avait invité, c'était en deux mille seize.
Il y avait le Star Wars qui sortait et il cherchait des chroniqueurs pour-- parce que-- enfin pas des chroniqueurs, mais des gens pour assister un peu Hugues Dayez qui s'en fiche royalement de toute cette culture geek.
Donc j'avais été invité avec trois comparses dans l'émission. Et je me souviens qu'effectivement, à un moment donné, un de mes comparses explique qu'il allait revoir le film une deuxième fois.
Et alors, Hugues a sorti une phrase, je sais plus : « Ah oui, pendant que ta femme faisait les courses, toi...
» Et ça sortait de nulle part. Et c'était, ouais, ça revient assez souvent en fait.
Mais c'est une autre génération hein. C'est-
Ouais.
C'est... voilà. Et qui insiste sur son droit très légitime à rire de tout et à s'exprimer sur tout. Mais ouais, nous, je-- bah, ça reste, je trouve, une émission intéressante.
Et puis je suis allée même avoir la COD live, là-
Ouais.
Qu'ils organisent de temps en temps. Ils étaient à Flagey. Et il y a une ferveur dans le public qui est hallucinante quoi.
Alors que je connais pas les chiffres du podcast, mais j'imagine que comme tout podcast en Belgique, ça doit pas être non plus fou.
J'avais vu Rudy dire qu'il était téléchargé un million de fois par an quoi. Donc c'est-
Ah ouais, ouais.
Là, oui, là, il a son petit succès hein.
Oh bah, mais franchement, mais je sais quoi-
Et dans un dernier épisode, il explique que la femme de Didier Landers et la reine Mathilde écoutent le podcast.
Ah ouais ?
Je sais pas si c'est vrai, mais voilà.
Ouais, sûrement. Sûrement.
Ouais, donc tu n'écoutes plus trop Ciné-Cinéma, mais tu ne sais plus pourquoi.
Ouais, je sais pas. C'est parce qu'il y a tellement de trucs à écouter en fait.
Bah oui.
L'offre podcast a tellement explosé. Et peut-être que je m'intéresse un peu moi aussi au cinéma ces derniers temps.
J'y reviendrai sans doute à un moment donné, mais ouais, j'essaie plein d'autres trucs en ce moment.
Donc on le disait aujourd'hui, tu t'es un petit peu diversifié ton champ d'action. Tu as publié l'année dernière un roman, Ariane.
Oui.
On va revenir dessus. Il a connu une très bonne réception. Il a été nominé pour un prix Goncourt.
Mh.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler de ton expérience avec cette nomination pour le prix Goncourt ?
Eh ben j'ai appris que j'étais nommée pour le prix Goncourt parce qu'une copine m'a envoyé un message de félicitations.
Et prix Goncourt du premier roman hein, pas prix Goncourt tout court.
Oui, oui, bien sûr.
C'est quand même moins prestigieux, hélas.
Toujours sympa.
Parce qu'une copine m'avait envoyé un message de félicitations et je voyais même pas à quoi elle faisait référence. Et parce qu'en fait, ils ne vous préviennent pas quoi.
Ça paraît dans la presse et moi, j'étais, je sais pas, chez le kiné ou j'en sais rien. Donc, je ne le savais pas, mais j'ai commencé à recevoir des messages et ça m'a fait un plaisir fou quoi.
J'ai passé un mois en lévitation, ça m'a-
Tu te sentais validée, légitimée.
Oui, oui, complètement.
Ouais.
Ça, c'était-- alors que j'avais tellement douté
de l'intérêt de l'existence de ce livre. Et puis là, une académie aussi prestigieuse qui sélectionne mon livre, j'étais-- surtout, 'fin, voilà, on n'était que cinq à être nominés.
Donc, tu recommandes la nomination au prix Goncourt.
Ah oui, oui, oui. Non, pour le moral, c'est vraiment excellent. Ça, c'est pour la peau, pour les cheveux, c'est super.
Oui. Et ça, c'était le début.
Oui.
Ensuite ?
Eh ben alors la suite, c'est que je reçois via ma maison d'édition un mail d'une certaine Marie Dabadie,
épouse de Jean-Loup Dabadie, pour ceux à qui ça parle,
qui est la secrétaire de l'Académie Goncourt et qui me demande de venir à Paris le 4 mai à 12 h 30 au restaurant Drouant me présenter pour la proclamation des résultats.
Très prestigieux restaurant, je crois.
Oui.
Ouais.
Mais je pense que c'est de la cuisine au beurre bien, bien grasse, bien tradi. C'est pas mon truc. Et puis voilà, je suppose que tout le monde est invité à se présenter au restaurant Drouant.
Donc, je prends un ticket de train, un hôtel. Mais la pression monte parce que la veille, je reçois de nouveau un mail de Marie Dabadie qui me dit : « La lauréate sera priée-- enfin, ira manger avec les membres de l'Académie.
» Sauf qu'en fait-- ah oui, et donc j'apprends à ce moment-là que nous ne sommes plus que deux en lice, mais elle parle quand même de la lauréate.
Et l'autre, c'est un garçon.
C'est ça.
Donc je me dis : « Est-ce que c'est un lapsus révélateur ? » ou je sais pas quoi. Mais déjà, je suis très excitée parce que j'apprends que nous ne sommes plus que deux.
Et donc je passe une nuit infernale à gober du Xanax, parce que je suis trop excitée pour dormir.
Et puis le lendemain matin, je m'étais même acheté un top que-- j'étais tombée par hasard dans un magasin sur un top dont la marque, c'était Brenda.
Et comme il y a un personnage qui se fait appeler Brenda dans mon roman, je me dis : « C'est un signe, je dois le porter, ça va me porter chance.
» Et parce que bien sûr, j'avais envie d'avoir ce prix pour le prestige, mais aussi pour le chèque qui était attaché au prix.
Ouais. Chèque de combien ?
De cinq mille, pensais-je. Oui, oui. Et comme j'ai eu une année un peu de vache maigre, franchement, je crache vraiment pas sur ce genre de petites raouettes.
Et donc je me présente au restaurant Drouant, mon éditrice me rejoint. Il est midi vingt, vingt-et-un, voilà, les minutes passent.
Et puis, quelques minutes avant midi trente, un communiqué de presse part et c'est Mayer Guen, donc pas moi, qui remporte le concours du premier roman.
Je me dis : « Ah bon. J'aurais mieux fait de rester chez moi. » Mais bon, voilà, c'est une bonne expérience. Et puis j'imagine que je vais aller dî-
Voilà.
Déjeuner-
Tourne la page, voilà.
Ouais.
Tant pis.
Et puis, voilà. Donc le jury descend de son escalier pour annoncer les résultats. Et quand c'est autour du roman, parce qu'il y a les catégories nouvelles aussi et poésie.
Quand c'est autour du roman, Bernard Pivot, qui est le président de l'Académie-
Ouais.
Dit : « Le concours du premier roman est attribué à Mayer Guen pour Grand frère avec six voix contre quatre à Hélène Lenoir.
» Et je me dis : « Mais c'est même pas moi. » Alors, je croyais que c'était-- j'étais deuxième. Je fais : « Qui est cette Hélène Lenoir ?
» Et puis Philippe Claudel qui lui donne un coup de coude en disant : « Non, non, tu t'es trompée de ligne. Ah non, contre quatre voix à Myriam Leroy, qui nous fait la surprise d'être là.
» « Pourquoi ? Je ne vous fais pas du tout la surprise d'être là. On m'avait demandé de venir. Qu'est-ce que-- » La gêne, parce qu'en plus, tout le monde se retourne vers moi en disant : « C'est quoi cette espèce de pique-assiette,
qui s'incruste ?
» Bon. Et voilà, moment relativement gênant quand même. Heureusement, j'ai l'occasion de discuter avec Virginie Despentes, que j'adore, qui fait partie du jury.
Donc c'est gai, avec Philippe Claudel, avec Didier Decoin, qui sont des auteurs que j'aime beaucoup. Donc ouais, ça reste quand même un moment assez chouette.
Ils me disent des trucs super sur mon livre, donc ça me ragaillardit. Et puis on me dit : « Allez, bon retour à Bruxelles.
Nous, on va manger. » Donc là, je comprends que le perdant n'est pas autorisé à aller manger avec la prestigieuse académie.
Donc, je vais en face dans une brasserie pour quand même manger un truc quoi.
Ouais.
Et puis là, mon éditrice me dit-
La brasserie du perdant.
Ouais, c'est vraiment ça. L'éditrice me dit : « Myriam, ne bouge pas. On a reçu un mail de Marie Dabadie qui te demande de te présenter au premier étage du restaurant pour recevoir ton chèque de trois mille huit cents euros.
» Et je dis : « Mais c'est quoi ce chèque ? Je savais pas que les seconds recevaient un chèque. » « Moi non plus, mais voilà.
Regarde, je t'envoie le mail. » Et en effet, je vois que Myriam Leroy est priée de se présenter pour recevoir son chèque. Bon.
Donc, nous montons au premier étage, mais ils sont déjà tous assis.
Moi, je suis hyper gênée quoi. Donc, je me cache derrière une espèce de cloison pendant que-- c'est mon éditrice qui toque à la porte en disant : « Bonjour, on nous a dit de nous présenter.
» Et le serveur fait : « Nous sommes au complet, madame. — Oui, mais c'est parce qu'en fait, Marie Dabadie-- Marie Dabadie ne travaille plus pour nous, madame.
» Et il nous ferme la porte au nez.
C'est le serveur qui dit ça ?
Ouais.
Mais donc-
Ça devait être le serveur. Je sais pas, ça devait être un des organisateurs de la-
D'accord, OK, ouais.
De la cérémonie, ouais, voilà. Marie Dabadie ne travaille plus pour nous. Je dis : « Mais c'est quoi cette histoire ? »
Le twist.
Et donc je Google-
C'est un film de M. Night Shyamalan.
C'est génial. Et je google Marie Dabadie.
Elle était morte depuis trente ans.
Elle était morte depuis trente ans. Non, elle avait été renvoyée de l'Académie Goncourt trois mois plus tôt.
Ouais.
Elle travaille plus là. Donc en fait, j'aurais jamais dû recevoir. Je sais pas ce qui lui a pris à cette femme de m'envoyer des mails.
C'est presque la partie la plus délicieuse de l'histoire. C'est qu'on se dit, il y a une fille qui est enchantée de ruiner la vie des gens et des nominés.
Non, mais c'est hallucinant parce que, allez, si tu veux te venger des gens qui t'ont virée, ce que je peux comprendre, tu te venges sur eux, pas sur un obscur auteur qui, de toute façon, ne pourra pas transmettre l'information.
C'est tellement cruel, c'est tellement gratuit.
Ouais.
J'adore.
Mais j'étais bel et bien deuxième. Donc, 'fin voilà, c'était-- Et puis ça a été une expérience et j'en ai fait une chronique qui m'a fait assez rire en fait, parce que c'était...
En fait, ce genre d'histoire, je sais pas si ça n'arrive qu'à moi, mais ça m'arrive beaucoup. Donc voilà, je suis passée un peu spécialiste dans l'art d'accommoder ce genre de restes.
Donc, on va revenir sur ton roman, Ariane, que tu as publié l'année dernière. Beaucoup de sujets qui reviennent assez souvent.
La narratrice, ça n'est pas Myriam Leroy, mais on soupçonne, et tu me diras si je me trompe complètement,
on soupçonne qu'il y a beaucoup-- 'fin, il y a quand même une certaine-- dans une certaine mesure, il y a du Myriam Leroy dans la narratrice.
Mh.
Dans le personnage principal.
Dans tous.
Dans tous ?
Oui, oui, bah-
Tu es à la fois le personnage principal, tu es à la fois Ariane, tu es à la fois les parents d'Ariane-
Oui, mais oui.
Tu es à la fois le...
Bah oui, bien sûr. Bah encore une fois, on écrit de-
Ouais.
De son point de vue quoi. Donc...
On peut aussi caricaturer les autres.
Ouais, c'est vrai. Mais il me semble avoir mis de moi et de pas moi un peu partout.
Mais donc un sujet qui revient assez souvent, c'est un petit peu la, je sais pas comment on appelle ça, mais la hiérarchie sociale quoi.
Oui.
Les bourgeois, les wannabe bourgeois-
Mh.
La classe ouvrière, les choses comme ça. C'est quoi ? C'est un sujet qui t'a-- parce que tu as toi-même, tu as vraiment grandi dans le Brabant wallon, il me semble.
Oui.
C'est un sujet qui t'a vraiment entourée en grandissant ?
Oui, oui, oui. Ben moi, je viens d'un milieu
classe moyenne. Moyenne, 'fin voilà, papa classe ouvrière, père employé, mère au foyer, et ni riche ni pauvre, et somme toute un peu isolées quoi, donc sans partager la culture ni
du prolétariat ni de la bourgeoisie.
Je trouvais que c'était intéressant comme toile de fond pour un roman parce qu'on parle jamais que des choses très saillantes et de la très grande précarité ou de la très grande richesse.
Mais les gens moyens, un peu ternes. La banalité, c'est quelque chose qui est pas souvent mis en avant. Et moi, je me disais qu'il y avait peut-être quelque chose à faire avec la banalité,
qui fut et est à certains égards la mienne, encore aujourd'hui.
Le portrait des parents du personnage principal, c'est vraiment, ben, narrow minded. C'est-- on s'enferme dans ses préconceptions, dans le dogmatisme et on reste dans-- on est comme il faut, voilà.
Oui, sauver la face, sauver les apparences.
Ouais, ouais. Du coup bah c'est quelque chose que t'as connu toi-même, dans cette classe moyenne ?
Oui, ben, et que-- 'fin, c'est surtout le milieu au sens large quoi.
Ouais.
L'école, les cousins. C'était un-- j'ai quand même ressenti une forte pression à la conformité, ouais, toujours quoi.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Mais-
C'est-- ça touche aussi également à ce que, voilà, à l'autre toile de fond de ce roman qui est l'école.
Ouais.
Voilà. 'Fin, c'est vraiment-- tu dépeins l'école comme étant un lieu où on paye sa puberté très cher, où tu dis à un moment donné : « Devenir une femme avait l'air tout à fait désolant. »
Ouais. 'Fin, le personnage dit ça.
Oui, le personnage. Oui, oui, je crois que je vais faire d'ailleurs souvent ça.
C'est pas tout à fait moi.
Oui, 'fin, tu le dis à travers ton personnage, donc sans le dire. Tu dis que l'école est un lieu cruel, où il y a un classement des plus belles filles par les garçons.
Le rapport homme-femme, c'est t'es bonne ou t'es une pute. L'école, un lieu superficiel où on veut être populaire ou ne pas être paumé.
Mh.
Si l'école, c'est aussi nul, c'est-- je partage tout à fait le constat hein, mais si l'école, c'est un lieu aussi traumatique, aussi
une usine à, ouais, une usine à traumas, pourquoi est-ce que ça existe encore sous cette forme-là ?
Pourquoi ça ne bouge pas ?
Ben alors, je vais être très décevante et plutôt te renvoyer à Jérôme Colin, qui lui a des avis-
D'accord.
...très, très tranchés sur l'école. Moi, l'école, je crois que c'est comme la démocratie, c'est la moins pire manière d'organiser les choses quoi.
OK.
Mais y a moins mauvaise plutôt que la moins pire. Et alors moi, j'ai pas détesté l'école.
Tu déçois.
Mais parce que c'était, j'étais une bonne élève, donc c'était relativement facile pour moi.
C'est ça.
J'ai pas détesté l'adolescence non plus. Disons que j'ai pris l'école comme biotope de ce livre, parce que c'est pour moi un laboratoire social.
Et je trouve que le monde de l'entreprise est bien plus cruel que l'école. Ceci dit, aujourd'hui, je pense que je serais incapable de revivre
mes années d'adolescence, mes années d'école, vu que j'avais le cuir plus épais parce que moins attaquée, je pense, j'étais plus fraîche.
En fait, toute vie en collectivité est extrêmement brutale quoi.
Mh.
Et il y a certaines personnes qui s'en sortent mieux que d'autres et qui pigent les codes et pigent comment ça marche.
Et puis il y en a d'autres qui pigent un peu moins,
et voilà, c'est un peu plus compliqué pour eux. Mais sur le fonctionnement de l'école en tant que tel, j'ai pas tellement d'opinions parce que moi, je m'en suis plus ou moins bien sortie quoi.
Tu es très critique. J'ai l'impression, moi, quand je lis ce que ton personnage principal dit, donc pas toi,
j'ai l'impression que l'école, c'est vraiment l'enfer quoi, de la manière dont tu le dépeins dans le livre.
Ben alors, pour revenir à mon expérience personnelle, moi, j'ai connu plusieurs écoles au long de ma scolarité et j'ai connu des écoles de péteux et là, c'était horrible,
mais c'était relatif aux péteux et pas tellement à l'école.
Et puis j'ai fini par échouer. Non, échouer, c'est pas un terme adéquat parce que c'est-- j'ai fini par atterrir dans une école populaire, mixte, avec de tout.
Vraiment, c'était une école où il y avait de tout. Je sais pas si c'est encore quelque chose qu'on peut trouver aujourd'hui, mais c-- donc il y avait des riches, des pauvres, mais pas des très riches ni des vraiment très très pauvres.
Il y avait des Blacks, des Arabes, il y avait, pff, des Italiens et c'était super. Et là, j'ai vraiment passé-- 'fin, c'était génial quoi.
Je me souviens quasi de rien des cours, mais
tout ce qui était relationnel, tout ce que j'ai appris, 'fin, c'était vraiment là que j'ai appris la vie quoi, mais que mes années en école d'élite où on est censé te préparer à un futur de champion, c'était intenable.
J'aurais pas pu rester là plus longtemps.
J'avais lu il y a quelques années une description du système scolaire comme étant un endroit où on coince plein d'adolescents qui sont à la recherche d'une identité, qui n'ont pas vraiment de responsabilités, qui n'ont pas vraiment de,
de choses importantes,
de choses très importantes à gérer dans leur vie et qui donc vont se construire
une hiérarchie sociale un petit peu, très artificielle quoi, avec des codes pas clairement définis, mais qui tournent généralement autour de la masculinité, de la féminité, de
la puberté, de l'assurance, de, voilà.
Mais là, l'école dans laquelle j'ai commencé mes études secondaires, c'était une école de riches et une école où il y avait pratiquement que des garçons.
Donc comme chacun vient, il me semble, à l'époque, avec
des visions héritées de leurs parents, en plus,
ça faisait quand même un sacré trio de-- 'fin, cette triangulation rendait cet environnement intenable pour les gens comme moi, un peu plouc, pas très beau, et puis fille quoi.
Et fille surtout qui avait pas envie de,
pfff, pas de la fermer parce que j'ai jamais été une grande gueule en fait, j'ai toujours été plutôt discrète, mais qui ne supportait pas en fait l'enfermement quoi, d'être prisonnière dans un truc.
On t'enferme dans un stéréotype. Et-
Ouais.
...là, en étant, 'fin voilà, je correspondais pas au stéréotype en vogue, donc ouais, je pouvais pas être la reine du bal quoi, c'est sûr.
Mmm-hmm. Particulièrement en ce qui concerne, bah ton identité en tant que femme, parce que t'estimes que on t'a fait payer très cher la puberté.
Parce que donc dans le livre, il y a souvent la question des formes, de la honte d'avoir la puberté. Non, je n'ai pas vraiment mes règles, non, je-
Mmm-hmm.
...mes seins n'ont pas grossi, etc. Bon moi, évidemment, j'ai pas connu ça. Donc ça m'intéresse de poser la question.
Est-ce qu'il y a vraiment ça, à l'école, la honte de la puberté ?
En tout cas dans la mienne, oui. Dans celle où j'étais, oui. Et je pense que c'est pas le cas partout.
Mmm-hmm.
Et qu'en effet, quand t'es dans une classe où t'as trois filles pour vingt-deux garçons, pfff, c'est quand même un peu plus compliqué de commencer à avoir des seins que quand-
D'accord.
...c'est quand même relativement équitable en termes de nombre quoi.
Ouais.
Il me semble, j'en sais rien. Ou alors peut-être que c'était ma classe qui était une classe de gros cons et je peux pas généraliser.
J'en sais trop rien en fait. Mais
je crois qu'aujourd'hui, les choses sont quand même plus détendues quoi et qu'on-- 'fin, j'espère que la honte sociale et la honte tout court, la honte de genre, c'est un truc dont on est en train de revenir un petit peu.
Ce qui est intéressant également, c'est que donc au début du roman, le personnage principal n'extériorise pas vraiment sa féminité, elle est elle-même moquée, harcelée par les garçons.
Et puis, un été passe et elle change tout à fait sa manière de s'habiller, sa manière d'extérioriser sa féminité. Et là, c'est un peu la harcelée qui devient la harceleuse.
Mmm-hmm.
'Fin, qu'est-ce que tu essaies d'exprimer avec ce personnage qui elle-même la cible du harcèlement et qui devient une harceleuse ?
Alors, sur le harcèlement, je n'exprime rien de particulier en fait.
OK.
J'exprime juste un parcours de vie qui s'inscrit dans une certaine logique parce que apparemment, c'est souvent le cas, hein, les gens brimés deviennent des brimeurs, souvent.
Il paraît. Par contre, sur cette espèce de transformation physique où la jeune fille se sent extrêmement puissante, j'avais aussi envie de montrer tout ce qui était normes de,
normes imposées aux jeunes filles quoi, qu'à partir du moment où elle correspondait à tous les critères, elle se sentait validée et que de cette validation découlait un sentiment de puissance extrêmement, extrêmement fort.
Est-ce que c'est une façon d'exprimer un message féministe à travers ton livre, le fait de-
Oui, oui. Bah en fait, simplement décrire, 'fin, mon entreprise féministe à travers ce livre, parce que c'est pas un livre qui porte un message.
Mais d'ailleurs, il y a des gens qui l'ont trouvé sexiste.
Bah, tu dépeins une situation sexiste.
Oui, voilà. Bah, parce qu'en fait, j'avais juste envie de montrer ce que c'était la réalité d'une adolescence-
Ouais.
...au féminin, alors que la plupart des bouquins dans lesquels il y a des personnages adolescents, 'fin-- bon déjà, il y a peu de personnages féminins principaux.
Donc pour moi, c'était important que ce soit un personnage féminin qui porte le récit. Et
et puis surtout que c'est un personnage féminin qui ressemble aux filles que je connais, pas des espèces de libellules éthérées, fées clochettes ou reines de glace.
C'est toujours dans les romans, les adolescentes disposent. Les hommes, les garçons proposent, elles disposent et elles les éconduisent de manière très cruelle.
Alors que moi, dans mon souvenir, avec mes copines, on galérait à fond. On avait envie de sortir avec des garçons qui voulaient pas de nous, qui nous disaient qu'on était moches et on l'était certainement.
On était maladroites, on avait des boutons. C'était pas cet univers complètement factice, je trouve, qui est fort fabriqué par la fiction.
Donc c'est aussi pour ça que le personnage principal,
'fin, et tous les personnages. Il y a beaucoup de choses qui se passent au niveau du corps, des émanations du corps, des odeurs, de la transpiration, de la sueur, le maquillage qui coule, ce genre de trucs.
Parce que j'avais envie de redonner du-
Je sue beaucoup dans ton livre.
Ouais, on transpire à mort. J'avais envie de donner vraiment du corps et quelque chose de concret à ces personnages quoi, qu'on sorte un peu toujours de cette, du cliché de la jeune fille de Virgin Suicide quoi.
Mmm-hmm. Tu parles aussi beaucoup des magazines féminins dans ton-
Ouais.
...dans ton livre. Comment est-ce que tu expliques que ces magazines féminins,
là, on sort un petit peu du cadre du roman, mais légitimisent et encouragent le conformisme de se conformer à des rôles genrés bien définis, à une apparence
féminine bien définie, plutôt que de faire le contraire, en fait, plutôt que de dire : « Mais libérez-vous, fond d'une pipe ».
Bah, ouais, je pense qu'il y a toute une série de raisons à ça, notamment les annonceurs quoi. Les magazines féminins, il y a quand même une page sur deux, c'est une pub pour du parfum ou pour
pour des choses, des articles de mode.
T'sais pas, par conformisme.
Mmm-hmm.
J'en sais rien, c'est difficile à dire.
Ouais, c'est difficile. Le-
Mais c'est, mais en fait, ça fait vraiment tellement longtemps que je les lis plus que je- ...sais pas vraiment ce qui s'y trame quoi.
Ouais. De temps en temps, j'entends des gens qu'on appelle des masculinistes poser la question de manière un petit peu tendancieuse : « Tiens, mais pourquoi est-ce que les femmes portent du maquillage ? »
Mmm.
Et il y a des réponses très variées à cette question rhétorique, voilà, qui-- la réponse présumée, c'est du genre : « Bah parce qu'on veut absolument séduire les hommes, tout ça, machin ».
Mais du coup, j'ai envie de te poser la question : pourquoi est-ce que les femmes portent du maquillage ?
Ben, je pourrais évidemment pas répondre à cette question sans prendre environ dix-sept heures de ton temps. Et je te renvoie à un bouquin de Mona Chollet qui s'appelle Beauté fatale, les nouveaux visages de l'aliénation féminine qui est super.
D'ailleurs, il faut lire tous les bouquins de Mona Chollet. Elle vient d'en sortir un qui s'appelle Sorcières, qui est super.
Et avant ça, c'était Chez soi, une odyssée de l'espace domestique qui est sur les lieux d'habitation.
Impossible de répondre en moins de dix-sept heures.
Non, non, c'est-- alors, il y a--
la beauté est un outil de séduction et la séduction est le rôle dans lequel on valide socialement les femmes et aussi peut constituer un outil d'émancipation sociale si on décide de jouer la partie selon les règles qui nous précèdent.
C'est-à-dire qu'une femme peut, née dans des milieux modestes, peut s'en extraire en séduisant des hommes riches.
D'accord.
Voilà, je caricature extrêmement, hein.
Ouais, non, mais c'est intéressant. Donc ça montre qu'il y a vraiment-
La beauté est un-- on peut l'avoir comme un outil ou comme une obligation, quoi.
Ouais.
Mais je suis surpris, en fait, de ne pas voir dans cette ère très féministe, très MeToo, etc., de ne pas avoir plus de femmes se dire : « Non, c'est-- je ne veux plus me maquiller ».
Ben, en fait, il y en a. Il y a le retour des poils aussi, surtout. Mais c'est hallucinant, quoi. Il y a beaucoup-- quelques instagrameuses qui se montrent avec des aisselles légèrement poilues, elles reçoivent des menaces de mort.
Donc c'est-- 'fin, vraiment, on est dans un-
C'est toujours intéressant. La menace de mort, c'est presque, 'fin, voilà, on touche à quelque chose de très gênant.
Ah oui, donc ça a l'air du tabou ultime, quoi, les aisselles poilues, de-- tu peux dire toutes les horreurs du monde, mais alors, si tu n'es pas bien épilée sous les bras...
La fille de Madonna, Lourdes Ciccone, qui était une-- elle n'est pas instagrameuse, mais c'est un peu une icône de mode.
Et elle a-- donc c'est une fille extrêmement sophistiquée dans l'apparence, mais elle a les aisselles poilues.
Et ça, mon Dieu, je me demande si elle doit pas sortir de chez elle avec dix gardes du corps pour éviter qu'on la bute, quoi, parce que ça, ça rend les gens fous, quoi.
Ouais. Puisqu'on parle un petit peu de féminisme, etc., j'ai envie de rebondir là-dessus pour évoquer le cas de, alors c'était l'été dernier, de Damso, donc le rappeur belge,
qui avait donc été choisi pour être l'hymne de-
C'est l'hymne des Diables Rouges ou...
Oui, oui. Et donc rappeur gangsta rap. Moi, j'y connais rien, donc je dis peut-être une bêtise en disant ça, mais...
Ouais, pas trop gangsta. Oui, on peut.
On peut aller. Et donc voilà, des paroles pas toujours très respectueuses, pas toujours très inclusives.
C'est bien ton art de l'euphémisme.
Oui, c'est vrai que je-- comme ça, j'évite les menaces de mort.
Oui, oui, on voit. C'est bien.
Et donc il y avait eu des demandes auprès de la Ligue de football de revenir sur cette décision. Personne n'a bougé.
Et puis Alexander De Croo, je crois que c'est lui, en tout cas, est allé-- qui est donc le ministre en charge des télécoms et donc de Proximus, est allé voir Proximus en disant : « Ben non, on retire le sponsoring
des Diables Rouges s'ils ne reviennent pas sur cette décision ».
Et là, les choses ont bougé. Et alors, je me souviens que j'avais fait un petit post sur Facebook pour valider cette action politique.
Et je me souviens que les gens étaient très énervés. Les gens-
Oui.
Et je me souviens que c'était particulier. Donc moi, je connais des gens à l'ULB, des gens au Saint-Pierre, des gens à Molenbeek, voilà, des groupes d'amis un peu partout.
Et c'était surtout, ben, les gens issus de Molenbeek, les gens issus de-- j'aime bien cette formule, les gens issus de la diversité.
Oui, c'est super. C'est creux à crever.
Oui, je crois qu'à force de faire du mémétisme et d'essayer de parler comme une bête en radio, je prends aussi les-
Oui, oui, c'est bien. Ton master en langue de bois est parfait.
Je fais très bien semblant, oui. Tu écoutes toi-même du gangsta rap, j'ai cru comprendre, et j'avais vu ton intervention sur BX1 à ce sujet.
Est-ce que tu estimes que c'était la bonne décision de revenir sur cet hymne des Diables Rouges ?
Non, je crois-- 'fin, j'en sais rien, en fait. Je trouve que tout ça était très hypocrite et très-
D'accord.
Cette séquence a été lamentable de bout en bout. Il fallait juste pas l'inviter, quoi. Il fallait juste pas le lui proposer.
Ouais.
Je n'ai aucune envie de censurer qui que ce soit et je trouve qu'il a par ailleurs beaucoup de talent, Damso. Et pour moi, il ne doit pas mourir, il peut exister, il peut continuer à faire de la musique.
Mais par contre, faire de lui l'auteur de l'hymne super rassembleur d'un grand spectacle familial, machin, brole truc, je trouvais ça complètement à côté de la plaque, quoi.
Mais c'est aussi dans un contexte où le football, c'est peut-être un peu plus les classes populaires. Les classes populaires sont peut-être moins sensibles à la question féministe.
Le football est aussi un secteur très, très machiste, secteur du sport, tout ça.
Oui, peut-être.
C'est peut-être simplement des gens qui s'en foutent.
Voilà. Oui, bien sûr que c'est ça. C'est des gens qui s'en foutent, qui voient pas où est le problème, quoi. Mais si tu vois pas où est le problème alors que tu es une huile de la Fédération de football,
il y a quand même un petit souci quelque part, quoi.
Il faut avoir les yeux un peu en face des trous. Damso, il a un répertoire qui est globalement extrêmement misogyne, quoi.
Il n'est pas que misogyne et d'ailleurs, les choses qui sont pointées chez lui, 'fin, quand il y avait toute cette déferlante d'articles,
qui pointaient la réaction rageuse des féministes contre un jeune homme issu de la diversité, car n'étaient-elles pas racistes ?
Et c'est pas pour ça qu'elles voulaient faire taire ce jeune artiste prometteur.
D'accord.
J'ai lu des trucs vraiment très pourris de ce genre-là.
On a toujours à tourner le truc de manière à avoir raison, c'est, ouais.
Mais c'était, oui, vraiment. Et c'était des tribunes qui étaient systématiquement signées par des hommes, ce qui fait que moi, j'ai décidé à un moment donné de prendre la plume et de faire une tribune dans Wilfried, d'ailleurs, moi-même.
Comme ça il y avait au moins une meuf qui s'exprimait sur le sujet. Et donc, on pointait des paroles de Damso qui, pour moi, étaient juste sexuelles, quoi, et pas sexistes.
'fin, il y a une espèce de confusion aussi autour de
l'expression crue de la sexualité et de la misogynie. Parce qu'il y a des trucs extrêmement misogynes qui n'ont rien à voir avec le sexe et des trucs sexuels qui n'ont rien à voir avec la misogynie.
Mais oui oui, c'était complètement-- 'fin, c'était au-delà de la maladresse quoi, de le convoquer pour faire ça et le rétropédalage qu'a suivi, ben c'est comme tous les rétropédalages quoi, c'est vraiment grotesque.
'fin je me dis qu'ils auraient même dû assumer jusqu'au bout quoi, au lieu de faire : « OK, très bien, oh, on va nous retirer des sous.
» Alors d'accord. Et que ça, ce soit la seule voix qui soit prise en compte, alors que le témoignage de milliers de femmes qui disaient : « Mais enfin, vous vous rendez compte, c'est quand même super heurtant ».
Ça en touchait une sans faire bouger l'autre. Je trouvais ça, ouais, désespérant de bout en bout.
C'est donc désespérant à travers les commentaires dans la presse, désespérant parce que de base, il fallait pas l'inviter.
Ouais.
Et mais le rétropédalage, je trouve ça curieux que tu le regrettes ? Par exemple-
Ben non, c'est pas que je le regrette, mais je trouve que c'est une mascarade quoi. Parce qu'en fait, le mal était fait.
Et bien sûr que Damso n'allait pas faire une chanson sexiste pour la Coupe du monde parce qu'il est pas con.
Ouais.
Et il aurait bien sûr commis un truc très bien. Mais c'est la décision de base, moi, que je trouve-
Mmm-mmh. Qu'est-ce qui est sexiste ?
Tellement légère quoi.
Puisque tu dénonçais justement les maladresses de tes confrères qui exprimaient très mal le problème dans le travail de Damso, qu'est-ce qui est sexiste alors chez Damso exactement ?
Pour écrire ma tribune sur Damso, que personne n'a lue, mais que je trouve très bien si je puis me permettre, j'ai quand même été tout écouter, tout le répertoire d'année en année donc-
Ah ouais, d'accord, oui, t'as travaillé.
Donc voilà, parce qu'il faut quand même savoir de quoi on parle hein, pour savoir ce qui est misogyne-- parce que c'est même pas sexiste en fait, parce que le sexisme, c'est une discrimination.
La misogynie, ou la gynophobie, c'est-
D'accord, oui.
C'est plus quelque chose de-
C'est-
Qui se travaille même inconsciemment quoi. C'est quoi ? C'est la chanson, le morceau Vagabond : « Tu me fais la bise, je sais même pas qui t'a sucé, la place de ta bouche est dans mon caleçon ».
Là, je pense qu'il y a même pas besoin de commentaire quoi. Ou alors-
On résume la femme à un objet sexuel, ouais.
Mais oui et un objet sexuel auquel on ordonne des choses quoi.
Mmmh.
« Je te prends que par derrière comme passagère sur ma bécane, je mettrai tout sur les réseaux. Oui, ta chatte sera ruinée, je vais te cramer au monde entier, grillée, je vais te cergeler ».
Donc c'est l'humiliation, l'humiliation sexuelle quoi.
Je mets toujours un teaser vidéo dans les réseaux sociaux où j'isole un petit extrait.
Mmmh, on fera celui-là. « J'aime la violence et voir le sang qui coule, entendre mes ennemis dire pardon sans leur pardonner, baiser leur meuf en leur transmettant la chtouille ».
Donc en fait, tout dans le-- 'fin pas tout, mais une grande partie des textes problématiques de Damso, et ils sont quand même nombreux, sont des textes d'humiliation par la pénétration quoi, pénétration symbolique quoi.
Et même quand il s'agit d'humilier un adversaire mâle, c'est toujours : « Je t'encule, pute » quoi.
Mmmh.
Mais il y a vraiment-- 'fin, il y a beaucoup de
Non mais quand tu me dis ça comme ça, j'ai l'impression que c'est valable pour à peu près-- bon, j'écoute pas assez de rap pour juger, mais-
Mais tout à fait, pour une grande partie de la scène rap. Ouais, c'est vrai que c'est très-- et alors les--
l'explication qu'on brandit souvent, c'est que les gens parlent comme ça, que dans la cour de récré, on parle comme ça, qu'on se traite de pute, qu'on traite les mecs de pute, « Je t'encule », machin.
Mh. C'est une explication plus que suffisante quoi.
Oui, c'est vrai que c'est une explication. Mais alors, est-ce que pour autant, il faut dire aux gens que ça heurte de la fermer ?
Parce qu'en fait, c'est pas que nous, alors je sais pas qui se cache derrière ce nous, mais que nous souhaitons faire taire les autres.
Nous souhaitons nous aussi parler, en fait. Et nous estimons que notre liberté d'expression
n'entame pas celle des autres quoi, mais qu'aujourd'hui, grâce à Internet, il faut faire aussi avec la contestation de ceux auxquels on s'en est toujours pris quoi.
On entend tout le temps des gens qui disent : « Oh, c'était quand même plus facile dans les cours d'école, dans notre jeunesse ».
Oui, oui, le texte de Les Amours s'est fait éjecter comme ça. Je parle du coq à l'âne hein, mais-
Oui et là-
Et il justifiait ça en disant : « Ben, de mon temps, quand il y avait quelqu'un qui dénonçait, on le prenait dans un coin et on lui pétait la gueule quoi ».
Oui oui. Et alors maintenant, on dit : « On peut plus rien dire ». Mais si, puisque tu passes ton temps à le dire. Le seul truc, c'est que maintenant,
il y a des gens qui te répondent qu'avant, ils le faisaient pas parce qu'ils étaient tout seuls, parce qu'ils avaient l'impression d'être trop faibles et que Internet donne un sentiment de groupe aussi
qui fait que quand tu dis quelque chose, tu sais qu'il y a des gens autres que toi, qui vivent la même chose et qui pensent la même chose que toi aussi.
Donc c'est simplement ça aujourd'hui. Il n'y a pas de retour de l'ordre moral. Il y a juste la naissance d'un tout petit peu de la voix de ceux qui en ont été privés toute leur vie quoi.
Oui. Il y a peut-être ici aussi ce qui apparaît comme une légère contradiction, c'est que tu es toi-même globalement amatrice de rap, de gangsta rap.
Mmmh.
On explique que-
Mais j'ai surtout écouté du rap américain, moi, quand j'étais plus jeune.
C'est mieux à ce niveau-là ou pas ?
Alors pas forcément. Mais-- alors c'était déjà une époque où le rap était pas tout à fait le même qu'aujourd'hui.
C'était quand même un rap plus politique, plus contestataire et social et tout ce que tu veux.
NWA, tout ça, oui.
Ceci dit, je veux pas faire la maligne. Moi, quand j'avais 20 ans, ce que j'écoutais, c'était des If You're Sexy and You Know It, It's Too Clap Your Hands et Move Bitch Get Out the Way.
On te demande pas forcément de justifier ce que t'écoutais à 20 ans.
Non, mais c'était de l'anglais, donc je comprenais pas tout. Donc ça pouvait pas vraiment me heurter quoi. Je le chantais en yaourt.
OK.
Et puis il y avait aussi un truc à l'époque, et je m'en rendais vraiment pas compte, c'était que
aimer ce que les garçons aimaient, ça permettait aussi de se faire une place dans le groupe, ça permettait d'éventuellement les séduire et d'accéder à quelque chose, une place dans le groupe dominant quoi.
Ça, ça sont des choses dont tu ne te rendais pas forcément compte à l'époque.
Non.
Mais au fur et à mesure des années, donc quand tu as pris conscience de plus en plus de ton engagement féministe, est-ce qu'à ce moment-là, tu as tourné ton dos au rap ou est-ce que tu as continué ?
J'en écoute de moins en moins, en fait.
OK. Et est-ce que c'est à cause de ça ?
Ouais.
Ouais ?
Ouais, ouais. Et ce que j'écoute, c'est du rap conscient ou du rap mélancolique de mecs torturés.
Ouais, ouais.
Et un peu des meufs, peu. Mais ouais, je suis allée voir le concert de Kery James à la Madeleine.
D'accord.
Et je trouve que c'est vraiment un type qui a une énergie tellurique vraiment dingue. Et puis c'est un des derniers rappeurs qui transpire l'engagement quoi, qui est dans une forme de combat.
Mais sa dernière chanson, il fait toute une liste de tous les défauts qu'il attribue à la lie de l'humanité.
Et puis il fait : « J'appelle ça comment ? J'appelle ça une prostituée. » Et
tout le monde dans le public : « Une prostituée ! » Et moi, après, sur Instagram, je lui ai envoyé un message en disant : « C'était super ce concert, mais permettez-moi de vous dire qu'il y aura peut-être une autre manière de qualifier les,
les mères du maire que de dire prostituée. » Et alors, il m'a répondu, il m'a dit : « Mais les hommes aussi peuvent se prostituer. » Je dis : « Oui, mais vous avez dit une prostituée. »
Et puis, et puis quoi ?
Enfin, tu vois, quand tu es un rappeur engagé, parce que c'est son cas, du côté des faibles quoi, pourquoi taper sur une catégorie qui est parmi les plus faibles, les moins représentées, les moins syndiquées de l'histoire.
Je trouve que c'est un non-sens total, mais c'est parce que c'est rentré dans le langage courant. Et moi, je crois que ce langage courant, on peut envisager de le travailler pour
trouver des alternatives créatives à ce type d'insultes.
Je reviens à ce que je disais tout à l'heure, c'est que le féminisme, c'est davantage quelque chose qu'on constate dans les gens qui ont été à l'université, les bobos, etc, pour ainsi dire.
Ici, on parle plutôt, dans le cadre du rap, on parle de manière générale plutôt des classes populaires.
Oui.
Est-ce que tu observes un quelconque mouvement vers une amélioration à ce niveau-là ou est-ce que c'est coincé ?
Ben en fait, je suis plus une observatrice suffisamment attentive de la scène rap pour pouvoir avoir un avis là-dessus, mais il y a des-
T'as essayé d'écouter, comment elle s'appelle, Aya Nakamura ?
Ouais, ben c'est aussi...
C'est difficile à juger.
C'est aussi-- mais en fait, j'aime bien parce que j'aime bien sa voix et j'aime bien ses rythmes. Et c'est ça aussi que j'aime dans le rap, c'est la rythmique quoi.
Et c'est ça qui me parle. Ça parle à mon corps avant de parler à mon cerveau. Et Aya Nakamura, elle parle très bien à mon corps quoi.
Mais si on...
Par contre, ton cerveau...
Oui, ben disons que c'est un peu le langage et les représentations lambda d'une fille produite de son environnement, de son temps, qui est travaillée et traversée par la misogynie quoi.
Voilà, c'est-- et on peut pas vraiment le lui reprocher, mais on peut espérer qu'un jour, il y ait des alternatives.
Cœur de Pirate sur Twitter la citait justement comme, mais presque, presque une démarche, un exemple de démarche émancipatrice.
Mais oui, il y a de ça aussi en fait.
C'est toujours très compliqué en fait. Parce que moi, quand j'écoute ça, je fais : « Ben, vraiment ? »
En fait, dans les textes, elle est clairement pas dans une démarche féministe, mais rien que le fait qu'elle existe et qu'elle se fasse son trou avec une certaine pugnacité.
Et puis c'est une fille qui rentre pas dans les canons instagramisants standards actuels. Donc j'imagine hein,
parce que j'en vois passer quand même beaucoup, qu'elle se prend pas mal d'insultes, qu'on lui dit : « T'es grosse, t'es moche, va te cacher, connasse, sale pute, machin. » Donc c'est quand même courageux quand on est une fille de s'exposer,
quel que soit le motif pour lequel tu t'exposes, que ce soit pour dire de la merde ou pour
dire des choses fortes super intelligentes.
Être le clou qui dépasse quand on est une nana, ça appelle le marteau. Donc ouais, il y a quelque chose effectivement d'empuissançant dans la démarche de Aya Nakamura.
Donc non, je déteste vraiment pas hein.
Tu détestes pas. Toujours sur le sujet, un petit peu, on tourne autour du pot de la question du féminisme. Quelque chose qui revient assez souvent, une attaque, une défense dans ce contexte de la part de certains hommes, c'est
la présomption d'innocence est complètement morte aujourd'hui.
On a trois accusations et c'est immédiatement vrai. On est jugé par un tribunal public dans les médias, etc. Qu'est-ce que tu penses de ce constat ?
Ben je pense que c'est une vue de l'esprit et que c'est une croyance parce que le backlash qu'a suivi MeToo a été extrêmement rapide, plus rapide que prévu.
Les femmes n'avaient pas encore fini d'exposer leurs doléances que on leur disait déjà de la fermer parce que c'était honteux et qu'on ne devait pas faire les choses comme ça.
Gnagnagnagna. Et donc ce qui revenait souvent, c'était : « C'est une démarche de délation. » Alors qu'en fait, Balance ton porc était vraiment une toute petite partie des prises de parole sur Internet.
Et les noms, c'était vraiment marginal, des gens qui balançaient des noms. C'était plus que marginal. Le hashtag MeToo, le hashtag Balance ton porc, c'était du partage d'expérience.
C'était moi, il m'est arrivé ça avec un collègue ou un supérieur hiérarchique ou avec un mec dans la rue. Et jamais les noms n'étaient cités.
Et il y a eu une focalisation de la part d'un certain public sur « Mon Dieu, on entend les bruits de bottes. »
Enfin, comme s'il y avait un quelconque parallèle à faire entre les dénonciations des Juifs pendant la guerre et les dénonciations des violences subies par les femmes aujourd'hui.
Donc ça me semble tout à fait, mais plus que déplacé quoi. En plus, c'est faux et ça contribue à faire croire que ça a été un mouvement de délation alors que ça a été un mouvement simplement de témoignage.
Oui. Je pense que quand ces personnes-là se plaignent de la sorte, c'est surtout en réaction des cas, entre guillemets, dans la presse people avec des célébrités un peu plus exposées médiatiquement.
Je pense par exemple à quelqu'un comme Tariq Ramadan-
Mh.
Qui a reçu quelques accusations. Et je ne veux pas prendre parti parce que ce n'est pas mon rôle, mais c'est vrai que immédiatement, tout le monde a fait-
Bah, Tariq Ramadan, c'est parce qu'une partie du public n'attendait que ça pour lui tomber sur le râble hein.
Ouais. Bah oui, mais donc ça va dans le sens de-
Donc c'est pas représentatif non plus des-
Non, c'est pas représentatif.
Du reste.
Est-ce que, même si ça n'est pas représentatif, est-ce que ça n'est pas problématique malgré tout ?
Bah non. Enfin, je vois, le tribunal populaire de Twitter-
Ouais.
Est forcément très agaçant. Une indignation en chasse une autre et un procès en chasse un autre. Mais là, en l'occurrence, je sais pas, est-ce qu'on a eu des histoires où
des hommes étaient injustement accusés, qui ont été cloués au pilori sur les réseaux sociaux et puis qu'en fait, ils étaient...
Non, j'ai pas l'impression ou alors ça m'est passé à côté, mais il me semble que toutes les affaires sont en cours, que la justice n'a pas encore statué et que les choses sont moins binaires que ce qu'on veut bien faire croire.
Donc Tariq Ramadan, je le trouve pas représentatif du reste. Plutôt des Luc Besson ou
Ouais.
Ce genre de truc-là.
En fait, je sais pas, ça dépend dans quel monde on veut vivre quoi. Dans le monde où DSK
qui agresse sexuellement
une femme de chambre s'est présenté par Jean-François Kahn comme un troussage domestique
et qu'on s'en fout et qu'on passe, enfin, son image n'est pas entachée parce que c'est arrivé trop tôt par rapport à la prise de conscience globale des
Ouais.
des violences subies par les femmes tous les jours. Ou est-ce que, ouais, alors, on ve--,
l'autre alternative, c'est peut-être qu'effectivement, tout le monde tombe sur le râble d'un mec qui a commis des erreurs dans le passé parce qu'aujourd'hui, tout le monde veut laver plus blanc.
Je sais pas. Moi, je trouve pas qu'avant, c'était forcément mieux quoi.
Si demain, on apprend que, je ne sais pas si c'est le cas ou je ne sais pas si ce n'est pas le cas, mais si demain, on apprend que Luc Besson est innocent, est-ce que ce n'est pas regrettable de dire que sa carrière, ses opportunités...
Mais sa carrière, ses opportunités, je pense pas qu'elles sont ruinées par ça. Il suffit de voir Louis C.K., Woody Allen, enfin voilà.
Et puis en fait, c'est comme tout. Il y a des fausses accusations, comme dans, enfin, hors champ du MeToo.
C'est légitime.
Ça a toujours existé, mais c'est, je crois, 8 % des accusations qui passent devant les tribunaux, qui s'avèrent finalement être une invention de la victime.
Et parmi les agressions, il n'y a qu'une portion tellement congrue qui sont portées devant les tribunaux que je pense qu'on, enfin, si tu-- je crois que c'est 10 %, même pas, des femmes violées qui décident de porter plainte.
Et dans ces 10 %, il n'y a encore que même pas 10 % qui se seraient, enfin-- donc tu fais 10 % de 10 % et là, tu as effectivement la scorie quoi, tu as le truc laid de l'invention de la victime.
Mais je pense que c'est le cas pour tout quoi. C'est pas
Je partage le constat de, voilà, c'est absolument tragique comme situation. Mais dis donc, aujourd'hui, avec les réseaux sociaux,
on est plus dans une situation où ce n'est pas un juge qui va juger de
la culpabilité de Luc Besson ou de Tariq Ramadan, c'est une place populaire qui va condamner et potentiellement, dans certains cas, heurter la carrière de ces personnes-là.
Ouais, bah écoute, quand ce sera le cas, quand il y aura une carrière indûment, lourdement endommagée par de fausses accusations, là, il sera toujours le temps d'y réfléchir et de statuer.
Pour l'instant, je n'ai pas, j'ai
Il faut réfléchir avant que ça arrive aussi.
Ouais, bah, ça arrivera peut-être pas. Qui sait ? Mais pour l'instant, bah moi, je crois que c'est quand même assez marginal quoi.
Oui, oui, c'est sûr. Oui, mais ça reste assez grave.
Bien sûr, mais on sait quand même que les dommages sociaux sont extrêmement, enfin, une femme violée va avoir plus de problèmes dans sa carrière que son violeur, limite quoi.
Oui, parce qu'on va essayer de
La honte est quand même toujours largement du côté de la victime dans ces cas-là. Et c'est aussi pour ça qu'elles ferment leur gueule.
Et c'est aussi pour ça que MeToo a été un tel appel d'air, parce qu'enfin, on pouvait raconter quelque chose puisqu'on se rendait compte qu'il ne fallait plus en avoir honte et qu'on pouvait l'ouvrir.
C'est mieux qu'avant quand même, non ? Un peu.
Moi, je trouve. Moi, je trouve que c'est super excitant comme moment et que c'est même l'occasion-- j'ai des copines qui n'ont jamais été féministes et qui me disaient : « Oh non, le féminisme, moi, j'aime pas.
Moi, je suis pour l'égalité ». Donc t'es féministe. Et qui comprennent aujourd'hui ce que c'est. Enfin, parce que je pense qu'il y a aussi beaucoup de femmes qui veulent pas voir parce que c'est trop dur.
Qu'à partir du moment où tu vois le monde tel qu'il est, putain, c'est vraiment, c'est pas réjouissant quoi.
Ouais.
Et donc se voiler la face, c'est une stratégie de survie. Et je les comprends et je ne les blâme absolument pas quoi.
Oui. Par rapport à tes copines qui, justement, voyaient le féminisme d'un mauvais œil, il y a évidemment dans tous les mouvements politiques, toujours des extrêmes hein.
Je pense au hasard aux Femen, par exemple. Il y a toujours ce fameux cliché qui revient assez souvent, à l'alt-right en Amérique, c'est
les jeunes avec des cheveux bleus qui ont des idées bizarres sur le genre et tout ça.
Ouais.
Entre, je cite.
Est-ce que les personnes les plus extrêmes, entre guillemets, qui portent ce message avec
le plus d'engouement, de manière très vocale, n'ont pas parfois, et je dis ça par rapport à tes copines, par rapport à mes amis à moi qui ont souvent eu aussi des
des réactions similaires, est-ce que ces personnes-là n'ont pas parfois un peu gâché la réputation du féminisme ?
Bah moi, je trouve pas et je trouve que les Femen, c'est des boucs émissaires qui sont bien pratiques quoi.
Mh.
Mais l'action des Femen est justement intéressante parce qu'elle suscite ce rejet extrêmement fort de la part de plein de gens.
Et c'est ça qu'elles vont chercher. C'est parce que, c'est- Elles sont tellement haïes qu'elles ont une raison d'être quoi.
Se foutre à poil avec des slogans sur les seins,
Mmm-hmm.
Et jeter de la mayonnaise ou je sais pas quoi sur la tête d'un homme politique. On peut pas parler quand même d'une violence absolument insoutenable hein.
Ça reste du Noël Godin folklorique, mais ça dérange extrêmement les gens. Donc si ça dérange, c'est que ça a pour moi tout à fait sa place.
Les Femen, c'est un phénomène assez complexe parce qu'en plus, elles viennent d'Ukraine. Donc il y a tout un-- elles charrient un truc culturel qui ne nous semble pas forcément adéquat pour nos discours dans nos sociétés.
Mais moi, je trouve qu'elles ont vraiment le mérite d'exister. Je trouve que c'est vraiment des filles courageuses.
Et le fait qu'elles embêtent à ce point les gens et qu'elles-- alors que c'est assez marginal, l'action des Femen. Le féminisme ne se résume certainement pas aux Femen.
Et on les voit une fois de temps en temps faire des coups d'éclat médiatiques parce que ce sont des femmes médiatiques.
Elles viennent avec des caméras, elles se font filmer. C'est pour la photo, elles le font pour la photo quoi, et pour le discours qui va découler de la photo.
Mais je veux dire, à côté de ça, tu as
Tu n'as pas en tête un mouvement féministe qui a pu aller-- être trop extrême, aller trop loin ?
Non.
Ça n'existe pas ?
Non, ben moi, je vois pas... Moi, je me considère comme radicale et ça veut pas dire être extrême. Moi, je trouve que c'est juste du bon sens quoi.
Il y a pas de discrimination acceptable ou OK. Donc enfin, moi, je-- tout m'énerve. Tout, pour moi, est un combat légitime et noble à mener.
Et il y a des combats qui prêtent à sourire du côté de certains, comme la féminisation des noms de métiers ou des noms de rues ou l'écriture inclusive.
Et alors, quand on a le malheur de brandir une parole par rapport à ces sujets-là, on nous dit toujours : « Tu desserves ta cause, tu te trompes de combat. »
Tu te trompes de combat, ouais.
Et je trouve ça hallucinant. Enfin déjà... Ah, et alors, c'est quoi le combat ? Attendez, dites-nous un peu. Expliquez-nous un peu quel serait le bon combat.
Enfin, tous les combats peuvent être menés conjointement. On va pas en poursuivre un en mettant tous les autres au frigo, en espérant que le premier se gagne.
On peut tout mener de front, il y a pas de
Et du coup, les personnes qui se disent, voilà, qui tiennent ce discours de dire : « Non, le féminisme, je ne crois pas trop.
Moi, je suis equalist. Voilà, je crois à l'égalité, etc. » Tu expliques ça par
Par un manque de connaissances.
Manque de connaissances ?
Oui. Par ignorance.
Mais il est dû à quoi, cette ignorance ? Les personnes qui vont présenter le féminisme comme
le mauvais combat et qui vont exprimer qu'en réalité, il faut plutôt chercher l'égalité, voilà, tenir ce genre de discours, que tu as tout à fait raison de dire que c'est plutôt ignorant et que c'est mal comprendre le féminisme que de dire ça.
Oui, parce qu'en fait
Mais cette mauvaise compréhension
Elle viendrait d'où, c'est ça ?
Est-ce qu'elle ne vient pas de féministes qui sont, qui ont un message un peu trop extrême et trop choquant et trop
Pour moi, ça vient certainement pas des féministes. Ça vient peut-être des choix médiatiques qui sont opérés autour des...
Moi, je préférerais qu'on donne la parole pendant une heure à Mona Chollet tous les soirs à la télé que de faire un travers de trente secondes sur les Femen qui n'est même pas creusé et dont on ne comprend même pas la démarche.
Enfin, il y a des tas de féministes, de tas de sensibilités différentes. Il y a des abolitionnistes par rapport à la prostitution.
Il y en a pas du tout. Il y a des anti-voiles et il y en a qui sont pour le libre choix. Il y a des pro-sexes et puis il y a aussi des, qui ne s'inscrivent pas du tout là-dedans.
Il y a l'écoféminisme, tout un mouvement de sorcières. Et puis aussi, enfin, il y a surtout énormément d'intellectuels quoi, qui
qui réfléchissent aux questions de genre et qui pondent des bouquins absolument passionnants, qui ne sont pas médiatisés parce que,
ils sont trop compliqués à schématiser.
Bien sûr.
Et donc forcément, le grand public qui ne s'intéresse pas à ces questions, les seules fois où on lui parle de féminisme, c'est quand il y a des coups d'éclat et des happenings politiques.
Parce que c'est ça, les Femen, c'est des happenings politiques, mais c'est vu comme étant des pantomimes violents, alors que ça ne l'est absolument pas.
C'est violent parce que, enfin, c'est une irruption brutale dans le cours normal des choses.
Oui.
Mais c'est
C'est ça qui crée le choc.
Mais ça crée un choc. Et, mais je-- voilà, si vous voulez savoir ce qu'est le féminisme, lisez quoi, lisez des livres.
Moi, j'ai une petite bibliothèque idéale de livres féministes qui sont super et qui sont très subtils et qui pourraient parler à tout le monde.
Mais quand je dis aux gens de les lire, quand ils me disent : « Tu trouves pas que le féminisme, c'est un peu un combat de gna, gna, gna.
» Je leur dis : « Mais lis ça, ça, ça, ça, ça. » Et : « Oh, mais j'ai pas le temps en ce moment. » Mais t'as le temps d'avoir une opinion, mais t'as pas le temps de te renseigner avant d'avoir une opinion.
Ben alors, qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ? Arrête de m'en parler quoi.
C'est le problème de la démocratie, ça.
Oui.
Ben, j'ai envie de rebondir là-dessus puisque tu parles, voilà, de ce camp d'en face. Sur le plan intellectuel, en ce qui concerne précisément le combat féministe, c'est qui ton adversaire le plus fin, le plus intelligent ?
Celui qui te, que tu ne classes pas au rang des abrutis.
Et ben, alors, je sais pas si c'est un adversaire, mais
Celui ou celle.
Le philosophe François De Smet va sortir dans quelques semaines un livre qui s'appelle Eros sur la logique économique à l'œuvre dans le
D'accord.
Dans le sexe quoi, en gros, dans les relations amoureuses. Et
c'est un copain et il m'a demandé de lire le livre avant, enfin, le manuscrit, avant qu'il sorte, avant même qu'il le remette à son éditeur, parce qu'il sait que je m'intéresse à ces questions.
Et si j'avais un avis à formuler ou s'il commettait des maladresses ou des imprécisions, voilà, il m'invitait à le lui dire, ce qui m'a fait plaisir parce que c'est un type d'une intelligence insoutenable.
Et ce livre m'a pas fait du bien parce qu'il est brillantissime. Il est relativement implacable, même si certaines sources qu'il convoque, moi, ça me donne de l'urticaire.
Je ne les trouve pas toujours très crédibles, mais il arrive à en faire quelque chose d'extrêmement crédible. Et donc c'est la- Bon c'est impossible à résumer puisque c'est six cents pages, mais il y a quand même un arrière-goût de--
profondément cuisant pour les féministes quand on
D'accord
lit ce genre de livre.
T'as l'air de parler presque d'un sentiment de défaite, c'est ça que tu dis ?
Non, pas de défaite, mais de-- disons que c'est le genre de livre qui peut donner du carburant aux mascus quoi.
D'accord. Si on le lit mal, si on le comprend mal ou bien même en le comprenant bien ?
Ouais, même en le comprenant bien, on peut, ben c'est comme tout, on peut faire de toute information une utilisation délétère quoi.
Et alors, je considère pas du tout François De Smet comme un adversaire, mais comme un partenaire.
Mais là, enfin, et c'est même assez stimulant quoi, j'avais un discours qui ne me plaît pas, qui me dérange, mais qui me fait réfléchir quoi.
C'est quand même très rare hein, parce que
la plupart du temps, je n'ai même pas envie de réagir à ce que je lis ou à ce que j'entends parce que j'ai l'impression qu'en face de moi, j'ai un interlocuteur qui me dit que la lune est un fromage de roquefort.
Donc enfin, on ne peut pas parler d'astronomie ensemble quoi.
Myriam Leroy, on arrive tout doucement au bout des septante minutes. J'ai une question bateau à poser. C'est quoi ton plus grand regret ?
Waouh, de-- probablement d'avoir trop été un bon petit soldat.
Bon petit soldat ?
Ouais. Poli, bien élevé.
Par rapport à qui ? Par rapport à quand ?
Par rapport au monde du travail.
D'accord.
J'ai toujours fait ce qu'on me disait de faire.
Et c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui ?
Un peu, mais de moins en moins. Maintenant, j'ai plutôt tendance à me retirer.
D'accord. T'as plus de statut, donc tu peux te le permettre, peut-être.
Non. Oui, oui, peut-être, mais enfin, en tout cas, j'ai pas les rentrées financières suffisantes par rapport à la fierté que j'ai. Mais...
C'est un regret qui couvre beaucoup de regrets, j'ai l'impression.
Ouais.
Qu'est-ce que t'as fait qui, par exemple, contre ta volonté ?
Alors, c'est pas vraiment contre ma volonté, mais j'ai longtemps accepté des boulots qui m'intéressaient pas parce qu'il y avait une éventuelle promesse d'accéder à quelque chose de plus intéressant par la suite.
Ok.
Sauf qu'à partir du moment où tu fais très bien, de manière très consciencieuse, un boulot qui ne t'intéresse pas, les gens ne voient pas la nécessité de te faire évoluer.
Et donc, tu végètes là pendant des années et tu vois les autres autour de toi qui
Ouais
qui prennent du galon, ceux qui ont dit non, ceux qui ont dit : Moi, j'ai pas envie de faire ça, moi, je veux ça. En fait, j'ai pas été chercher les choses quoi.
J'ai essayé d'être la collègue parfaite, l'employée parfaite, gentille, serviable, servile, même corvéable à merci.
Et ça m'a donné l'occasion d'expérimenter des tas de jobs, donc c'est pas inintéressant non plus. Ça fait aussi la richesse du parcours, mais je me rends compte que je me fais un peu chier quand même aujourd'hui.
Donc ouais, je pense que si je devais refaire les choses avec ce que je sais, je dirais plus facilement non, et j'exprimerais plus ce que je veux plutôt que d'accéder poliment aux demandes des autres.
Yes. Dernière chose, est-ce que pour se quitter, est-ce que tu aurais une recommandation culturelle, quelque chose que tu souhaites recommander à nos auditeurs ?
Oui. Alors là, j'ai lu coup sur coup trois romans de Lionel Duroy. Donc, ça n'a rien à voir avec le féminisme.
D'accord.
Mais c'est parce que, je sais pas, c'est, j'adore en fait ce qu'il fait. J'ai commencé par Colère. Comment expliquer ? Donc les trois romans que j'ai lus, c'est pas des romans en fait, c'est des récits.
C'est Le Chagrin, Colère et Écriture. Et ça tourne au fait toujours autour du même sujet, c'est-à-dire sa famille. Et un livre qu'il a sorti un jour où il racontait l'enfer que ses parents leur ont fait vivre à lui et ses neuf frères et sœurs.
Et il raconte ça et puis il raconte la suite de ça, parce que ça a été une bombe à fragmentation, la publication de ce livre, qui a décimé absolument tout ce qu'il avait de relations amoureuses, sociales, familiales, etc.
Et déjà, c'est des histoires passionnantes. Et puis c'est un type qui écrit avec une fluidité et une complexe simplicité.
Je sais pas bien comment le dire, parce que ses phrases sont assez longues, mais elles coulent quoi. T'as l'impression qu'elles viennent directement du cerveau du gars, que y a même pas eu besoin de passer par
par sa main quoi, pour directement t'arriver dans la rétine.
Et c'est assez-- j'adore quoi, c'est vraiment, c'est très beau.
Ok. Lionel Duroy, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
Ok, parfait, bien. Chers auditeurs, on recommande. Myriam Leroy, merci.
Avec plaisir.
On a passé septante longues minutes.
Longues ?
Mais non, je dis longues parce que-
Sympa
Non, non, parce qu'on a un petit peu dépassé, tout simplement. Myriam Leroy, merci beaucoup. Et chers auditeurs, on se retrouve dans deux semaines.
Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour ces Septante Minutes Avec Myriam Leroy. Je rappelle que vous pouvez trouver son roman Ariane dans toutes les bonnes librairies et en livre électronique.
Ça coûte une quinzaine d'euros. Il a été nominé au prix Goncourt du premier roman et c'est édité chez Don Quichotte. Dans le prochain épisode, j'aurai l'immense plaisir de recevoir Thierry Geerts, directeur de Google Belgique et Luxembourg.
On va parler technologie, bien sûr, mais on va surtout parler de pourquoi les Belges ont autant de mal à prendre en marche le train de la révolution numérique.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner au podcast sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée et sur les réseaux sociaux. Tous les liens sont dans la description.
Et quant à moi, je vous dis à dans deux semaines. Bye bye.